hmm our society has gone more and more
complicated in the last 100 200 years
a population has one from just a billion
it's an 8 billion
the Industrial Revolution has caused a
lot of globalization
under the most recent computing
revolution has made civilizations
knowledge be accessible at our
fingertips
our society has gotten a lot more
complicated the amount of accidental
mistakes that could be made that send
civilization into collapse has increased
we need to be more vigilant we need to
level up our wisdom fast
with all of these democratized
technologies
that make it easier and easier from
level and actors to wield immense power
for chaos and malevolence we need to
level up our wisdom fast fast
how many of us embody that how many of
us know that how many of us are sharing
exactly that sentiment with other people
around us hey guys our world has gone
really complicated we should probably
make sure that we don't go through any
civilization collapse moments like some
of our ancestors went through ok yeah
that's a good idea so then what do we
need to put into place in order to
ensure that hmm well we need to be
talking about morality a lot more we
need to be talking about philosophy a
lot more we need to be talking about
ethics a lot more hmm
ok well let's put these things in the
center of our conversational spheres
let's make sure that all of the people
working on the most cutting-edge
technology across biotechnology across
the neuro technology across artificial
intelligence and robotics across all of
these pressing fields let's make sure
that the people at the edge work
directly with philosophers ethicists and
moral scientists let's make sure that
that happens let's make that a priority
the democratization of the technology
enables a massive amount of creativity
it's gorgeous
how many more people are able to unleash
their creativity with these degrees of
freedom it's beautiful degrees of
freedom are beautiful they give people
their ability to figure out their
purpose more easily there's more choices
for you to figure out what your purpose
is where you fit into the world where
their children fit into the world
but the democratization of the positive
aspects also comes with the
democratization of the negative aspects
and we have to win the wisdom race we
have to level up our wisdom to make sure
that the malevolent actors that want to
take the democratized technologies and
use them for purposes of war for
purposes of corruption for purposes of
oppression that they cannot do that that
degree of freedom needs to be looked at
very very closely and it can be
completely completely avoided through
our ability right now to up level our
wisdom ahead of time ahead of time
the amount of examples of this about
people that have saved civilization from
mutually assured destruction
and you can look at them people like
Vasili arkhipov in 1963 with the Cuban
Missile Crisis people like stanislav
petrov in 1982 during the Cold War we
have to remember these are future of
life award winners in 2017 and 2018 like
Matthew meselson also helping renounce
biological weaponry that's the 2019
future of life award winner we have to
prioritize in knowing about people like
this we have to share these people with
our children to say that hey these are
the people and these are the ways that
our civilization has prevented collapse
in the past we must win the wisdom race
so think about that very very carefully
embrace those people into our
conversations not just the the pop stars
and the idols and all that stuff but can
we also embody the importance of people
that have saved our world from mutually
assured destruction can we make sure
that with the democratization of all
these exponential technologies that we
really prioritize morality we promote we
prioritize ethics and we prioritize
philosophy and we make sure to embed
those fields into every single
cutting-edge science that's currently
being worked on in cutting-edge
technology that's currently being worked
on
this is one of the most important things
of our time our society has gotten more
and more complex over time it's critical
for us to embody this wisdom let's win
the wisdom race we can do it together
have more of these conversations with
your friends families co-workers people
online talk to more people about these
subjects prioritize these conversations
and prioritize more philosophy morality
ethics at the edge of science and
technology prioritize it make it happen
together and remember as much as we love
the competition and how competing helps
us push the edge faster and faster we
also have to cooperate we all live on
one planet and future generations want a
beautiful planet to live on and to be
able to experience life on think seven
generations ahead just like the
indigenous elder to do it they think
seven generations ahead with every
action that they take think that many
generations ahead how do we win the
wisdom race
and remember that that wisdom that's
being carried from these elders for the
last Multi millennia transcends us are
25 50 75 year-old lifespans that wisdom
of thinking seven generations have had
of being tied in deeply to the ecosystem
that sustains us every breath of air
every drink of water every bite of food
every moment alive on this planet is a
blessing is a blessing of creation and
to be directly tied into that
spiritually is critical and that also
helps us get through the wisdom race tie
those things together we're building all
of these crazy general intelligences and
synthetic biology z' and neural
interfaces we have to slow down and
remember the wisdom of the indigenous
leaders on the world and the wisdom of
the philosophy the morality and the
ethics we can do this together have more
conversations about this I love you all
very much thank you for tuning in